not just chill like last year i my
parents uh invited me over and they
like through something it's just like
nothing i know it's nothing no birthdays
are weird
he can give all right look on the 23rd
of my birthday i got to play my uh
little sean this one here live on there
i mean i'd be my gift to you i guess
yeah i don't know from the fans i don't
think they're rebuttal
yeah they're about a man i don't i don't
yeah should we at big sean on instagram
dude i don't want that he i'm a fan so
you keep
saying i'm if he sat down right here i'd
be like
what's up dog you got to understand dawg
like
listen he name a big sean song
in the last two years that you like okay
i like that bring up this catalog
thank you
[Applause]
detroit ii lithuania you they don't
remember these i'm trying to tell you i
don't know
dog body language
body language stop it that evening those
are real boys oh what about one man can
change the world
2015 2015. thank you soon you see what
i'm saying y'all y'all
like when was your last hit that's
another good point on the 23rd on the
23rd
23rd y'all about it i'm about to wake
you all up rolly boy is about to wake
y'all up that's so funny yeah he doesn't
have a
ton of his thank you but he has a ton of
features too though exactly yeah he
kills it on the feature yeah
i want to hold big sean out i just want
a little taste of it
oh do you remember when kendrick lamar
got on his song control embodied him
yes oh yeah you see what i'm saying like
he's not listen no he had beef ever
since
where's that kendrick lamar how about we
wait i think it's coming i feel like
every time he's quiet for a while with
all this [ __ ] going on
yeah he's super he's super introverted
you know j cole was supposed to drop
last night
j cole it was trending on twitter uh it
just didn't happen it just didn't happen
they always do this why did they do
these thank you here's the thing who
announced the dropper
j cole announcer
he was like something's going to happen
at uh midnight y'all stay ready
why don't you tell us when it drops dude
but it's dope
because everyone runs and stream the
album if i tell you it's about to draw
like you playing
like i get around to it but if it's a
surprise droplet oh [ __ ] let me kill you
next morning
you have to make sure you're super
famous it seems like that's the wrong
thing
yeah drake did it with one of his albums
i'm just saying
if i was like i don't remember that can
you imagine i was like i might be in
palm beach end of the month
might not that's different though
people are like dude what the [ __ ]
hey y'all might want to be an apartment
beach if i want to see what
san marcos somebody go down
maybe or not i might not show up
i'ma let y'all figure that out somebody
popped up
can you imagine the worst marketing ever
walk-ups only what the [ __ ] yeah but no
we can't do that
yeah comics can't do that no comics
there's only one i mean
chappelle heart could do that but
charlie
he would do uh like big [ __ ] theaters
and do that
what yeah we'd be like yo chappelle's
hair tonight and he would announce that
morning oh yeah yeah he would he would
do that yeah
that's you know it would sell out you
have to be so i mean think about people
find babysitters and [ __ ] last minute
yeah yeah you're like this is once in a
lifetime he's going to be here music huh
they do that how about that
when i get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this is from a bunch of other
comics i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son